returning now to the pandemic the
diminishing coronavirus threat is
allowing americans
to return to their favorite places
including baseball parks
dodgers stadium played a key role in los
angeles fight
against covet it was one of california's
largest vaccination centers
now the stadium is back to what it was
built for hosting
dodgers games jamie yukas takes us out
to the ball game in our special series
spring into summer
fans are excited to see the dodgers
defend their world series title
in person after being forced to watch
the action on tv last year
but when you head to the ballpark
wherever it is you'll notice some
changes
for one anyone entering dodger stadium
over the age of two has to wear a face
mask unless eating or drinking and
across all major league ballparks
as you enter the stadium tickets will be
digital and scanned as you enter
last season the only fans allowed in
attendance were these cardboard cutouts
12 000 here alone but now fans are back
in the stands
but how many are in attendance varies
from park to park
dodgers stadium can hold up to 56 000
people
right now only about 15 000 are being
let in
they're seated in physically distanced
pods of two to six people
with unused seats closed off but if
you're
fully vaccinated teams like the dodgers
are allowing people to sit in these
specially reserved sections
where you don't have to social distance
but you do have to wear a mask
they're also offering a discount to
encourage fans to take advantage
one thing that is back to normal food
vendors hawking peanuts and beer you can
also walk up to any concession stand to
get your dodger dog
and payment is cashless and contactless
as people return to the ballpark fans
hope this is the bottom of the ninth in
the fight against covet
right now you know but i was confused
why do you have to wear a mask
outside if you're fully vaccinated and
they said california hasn't changed that
yeah i guess that's one of the other
things that's confusing as everybody's
roles are
yeah you've got a different place what
your state is saying and voucher did say
that or dr fauci did say
right you have to sit you have to check
in to see what the rules are where you
are yeah just like in when you go down
the street some stores tell you you got
to wear masks some say you're okay with
that come in